et pour débuter cette nouvelle séquence
du 78 un micro trottoir que pensez-vous
du départ du pape vous le savez Benoît
16 a décidé pour des raisons de santé de
quitter ses fonctions vos réactions on
en parle juste après avec le nouveau
responsable du Secours catholique dans
le département c'est une décision très
très surprenante dans la mesure où un
pape normalement démissionne pas et ça
fait bien longtemps que c'était pas
arrivé simplement effectivement vu
l'état de santé du pape ça me semble
assez normal alors franchement ça
m'inspire rien du tout je crois pas en
Dieu et ni au pape et encore moins à lui
voilà non ça m'inspirea rien du tout
j'ai trouvé bah super que quelqu'un PAP
ou n'importe qui puisse prendre ses
disposition pour ses raisons
personnelles et et puis partir d'un d'un
poste tout aussi important qu'il puisse
être là pour le PAP mais il a ses
raisons qu'il faut respecter pourquoi ça
sera un problème il y en a d'R derrière
lui va y en avoir encore
aprèsi c'est pas c'est pas une
catastrophe et je reçois donc François
pager bonsoir vous êtes le nouveau
responsable dans le département du
Secours Catholique pour débuter
forcément votre réaction après l'annonce
de la démission hier de Benoît 16 c'est
une première depuis le 15e siècle oui
c'est très très très
lointain première réaction admiration
courage choix politique mais surtout
vraiment l'idée d'avoir place sa
fonction comme un service être au
service et constater que peut-être il
n'a plus les capacités pour le faire
donc vraiment un grand respect de cette
décision politique qui je trouve
pourrait inspirer de nombreuses
personnes qui ont des responsabilités
dans ce monde Éric omonier l'évêque de
versaill s'est exprimé vient un
communiqué de presse pour lui Benoît 16
fut tout sauf un pape de transition il
aura profondément marqué les jeunes et
les moins jeune Benoît 16 ne cherchait
pas à plaire dit-il il cherchait à
servir la vérité de l'amour de Dieu il
l'avait RC rcontré d'ailleurs c'était en
novembre 2012 à Rome et il avait
remarqué he justement qu'il paraissait à
la fois à la limite de ses forces et en
pleine confiance en Dieu voilà pour les
réactions d'Éric auunier évêque de
Versailles François Paget vous êtes venu
ce soir pour nous parler également de
vos priorités puisque vous êtes le
nouveau responsable du Secours
catholique dans le département l'un des
dossiers prioritaires ce sera sans doute
le Programme européen d'aide au plus
démunis qui existe depuis 1987 l'Europe
via des subventions permet de nourrir 18
millions de personnes avec quelques 4
180 millions d'euros des associations
comme la vôre en bénéficie cela
représente parfois jusqu'à 50 % des
denrées alimentaires qui sont distribués
aux populations seulement certains pays
au sein de l'Europe comme l'Allemagne ou
le Royaume-Uni veulent que les États
reprennent ces aides à leur charge
justement et ce sera une difficulté
supplémentaire puisque Bruxelles a
décidé de baisser ses aides on parle de
plusieurs millions 1 milliard d'euros en
moins sur ce programme d'aide européen
pour le budget 2014 à 2020 quelle
conséquen pour vous aujourd'hui après
ces annonces qui ont été faites alors
premièrement je crois que cette décision
n'est pas totalement définitive il y a
encore voilà donc attendons d'avoir la
certitude pour regarder les conséquences
pour autant ça semble compliqué parce
que ce n'est pas la première fois c'est
vrai que ça avit déjà été remis en cause
et là les choses semblent plutôt mal
engagé donc première prière deuxième
chose effectivement ce sont des fonds
qui se tiennent surtout à l'aide
alimentaire et depuis de nombreuses
années le le Secours Catholique a choisi
d'être plutôt dans une logique
d'assistance long terme avec les
personnes de s'installer dans un
accompagnement long terme et d'être
moins dans un aspect de distribution
alimentaire ou vestimentaire et donc
c'est vrai que nous sommes un peu moins
que d'autres associations sensibles aux
conséquences de cette décision mais
c'est vrai que nos amis avec lesquels
nous travaillons comme le Secours
populaire la Croix-Rouge sont
effectivement plus impactés par cette
décision la région Île-de-France
Jean-Paul hchon qui a reçu récemment les
bénévoles des associations caritatives
franiliennes donc justement le Secours
Catholique et il a reconduit son soutien
à hauteur de 1 million 1 million d'euros
en fonctionnement un demiillion d'euros
en investissement ce sera utile ce que
représente la région justement pour le
Secours catholique dans le département
dans le département en fait les les
financements viennent principalement des
donateurs privés h donc la subvention
publique est assez marginale finalement
dans notre ensemble des ressources il
n'empêche qu'elles sont local sur les
municipalités départemental régional
national ou même international donc là
région est une des contributions mais
c'est relativement faible dans nos
ressources mais c'est toutefois
important de voir que c'est c'est c'est
maintenu pour l'instant dans un climat
plutôt difficile la région et
jean-pauuchon qui a soutenu hein donc
toujours ces associations franceiliennes
quelles sont vos priorités alors pour ce
mandat qui débute en tant que
représentant du Secours Catholique
exactement merci beaucoup donc je suis
très heureux de venir vous vous
rencontrer ce soir donc il y a eu un
grand travail participatif d'une année
dans toutes les équipes qui sont
présentes sur le territoire pour relire
finalement la pratique et définir des
nouvelles orientations donc je n'arrive
que pour mettre en œuvre ces
orientations qui ont été élaborées et
approprié par les équipes 70 équipes
hein sur le territoire des Yvelines on
parle de 2000 bénévoles au service de
15000 familles et personnes en
difficulté pour voilà donner un peu un
peu un ordre de
grandeur des priorités qui sont
principalement en fait les
familles les personnes qui sont
migrantes ou qui sont étrangères sur
notre notre territoire et puis les
personnes qui sont en difficulté de
logement ou d'emploi et vous vous
imaginez bien que ce sont des nombreuses
personnes et puis une priorité
différente c'est-à-dire de s'installer
dans la durée avec l'accompagnement de
ces personnes cherchez plus à être dans
la profondeur dans l'accompagnement vers
l'autonomie plus que dans l'assistance
immédiate distributive on va dire si
c'était un peu caricatural voilà et puis
quelque chose qui est plus
interne réseau de bénévoles donc 2000
bénévoles sur le territoire un objectif
pour moi de de
rajunir cette cette population pour
permettre à des jeunes ou des actifs de
pouvoir collaborer à des missions on
entend souvent pour les jeunes que c'est
difficile de par leurs activités pour
les actifs aussi vous les avez mentionné
comment vous allez réussir les faire
venir ça sera pas du jour au lendemain
voilà je pense que nous avons des des
révolutions internes du changement à
accompagné pour si on organise une
réunion toujours à 14h on a peu de
chance d'avoir des actifs présents donc
comment réinventer des nouvels modes de
de collaboration peut-être plus
partielle plus temporaire sur des
thématiques précises sur le logement sur
les aspects financiers utiliser des
compétences de personnes qui sont voilà
dans le monde bancaire ou dans
l'entreprise mais une une fédération
finalement d'énergie au service des
personnes en difficulté justement quel
est votre parcours professionnel
peut-être pour en arriver aujourd'hui à
je suis ingénieur pour pour le monde
industriel ingénieur commercial je suis
franc contois d'origine plutôt porteur
du valeur traditionnel de service j'ai
travaillé quelques années dans le
marketing et la finance à Paris et puis
je viens de de terminer 15 années au
sein de la communauté fondation où
j'étais donc au service pendant 8 ans
plutôt de l'organisation et de la
structuration générale au niveau
international et puis les se dernières
années plutôt sur l'aspect du travail
social l'accompagnement de jeunes qui
partent comme volontaire à l'étranger ou
l'appui à des projets de développement
dans l'éducation la santé l'insertion
économique en Afrique en Amérique du Sud
en Asie donc un peu voilà un peu
différent du territoire des ivelines
mais finalement ce sont des choses qui
VT nourrit justement l'expérience tout
ce que vous avez pu engranger et qui
vont vous servir maintenant pour exct
exactement c'est-à-dire que c'est fort
de cette richesse de la capacité à
comprendre des territoire lointain que
j'applique aujourd'hui pour comprendre
les ivelines et les différentes variétés
vous savez que nous sommes un
département très contrasté avec des
origines mais aussi des des manières de
vivre des des situations géographiques
financières mais aussi des difficultés
des personnes qui sont en difficultés
financière en difficulté de logement en
difficulté tout simplement et notre
devise au Secours catholique c'est
d'être proche de ceux qui sont loin quel
que soi leur leurs origines quel que soi
leur conviction avec les nôtres nous
mettre à leur service pour marcher vers
cette autonomie vous parlez d'un
département contrasté c'est une réalité
ce qui est aussi une réalité ce sont que
les difficultés sont de plus en plus
nombreuses dans l'ensemble des
territoires en France le rapport de la
Fondation Abé piierre au début du mois
l'avez souligné d'ailleurs vous en avez
forcément pris connaissance est-ce que
lorsque vous voyez justement cette
pauvreté qui devient de plus en plus
présente et ces difficultés de plus en
plus réell c'est c'est véritablement une
réalité est-ce que pour autant
quelquefois vous perdez espoir vous vous
découragez vous vous dites ça va être
très difficile pas du tout très
difficile mais au contraire c'est plutôt
mobilisateur je trouve que c'est une une
très belle occasion de montrer la
solidarité montrer le travail ensemble
je pense qu'on ne peut plus travailler
chacun dans son coin mais qu'il faut
fédérer l'ensemble des énergies du monde
associatif du monde des pouvoirs publics
pour ensemble chercher et traverser
cette étape qui peut-être sera longue
mais ensemble il y a de nombreuses
choses qui sont possibles pour conclure
votre priorité la priorité que vous vous
êtes posé là pour ce pour ce début le
premier rendez-vous qui sera
véritablement important pour vous
fluidifier les processus dans les
relations entre les différents
partenaires nos salariés les bénévoles
et tout ce mouvement profond au service
de la mission merci François pager
responsable du Secours catholique dans
le département des Yvelines depuis une
quinzaine de jours merci d'être venu sur
ce plateau nous parler de vos priorités
réagir aussi également à la démission de
benoî 16 et puis à ce plan d'aide
européen qui pourrait être fortement
réduit c'était une des informations de
cette semaine prochain point sur
l'actualité locale en direct mercredi
18h nous reviendrons sur l'installation
du siège de Mercedes à 50 ans yeline
nous parlerons également de la naissance
sous X une yvelinoise vient de publier
un livre témoignage bonne soirée sur
notre
antenne